oh it's an appalling ideology because
the people who created it had the idea
about what it should be before they made
it so it's propaganda you can say
exactly what frozen is about so it's
propaganda a truly mythological abased
story you can never fully say what it's
about you can just talk about it forever
and ever and ever and ever so it's it's
a wellspring of meaning so oh sure they
are of course that's what they're doing
oh yeah it's calculated marketing yeah
yeah sure
it was hyper politically correct yeah
yeah yeah and they didn't need men and
you know God give me a break you know
just because you need men doesn't mean
you have to like them yeah so so I mean
I've thought a lot about the difference
between propaganda and art so art is
actually a process rather than an end
product and with any luck if you have a
piece of art the process is embedded in
the byproduct and so it reflects the
process when you bring it into your
house and so it's an active it's a it's
a crystallized act of exploration and
the real artist doesn't know what
they're doing they don't know what
they're doing they're exploring I can I
can recommend a film there's a film made
of Picasso it in about 1957 and it was a
black-and-white film and it was actually
a film of him making a painting and he
painted it on glass so you could see
what he was doing it's really quite
fascinating because you can see that
he's playing he sketches it in and then
he rubs it out so he sketches it in
again and he rubs it out and he sketches
over here and it's like there's a real
dynamism about it he doesn't plan it out
to begin with not that there's
necessarily anything wrong with that as
an artistic endeavor - but Picasso was
trying to explore and understand and you
know I don't know what you know about
cubism but cubism it's a strange thing
but what he was doing with his cubism
was to try to show you that you only see
things from one perspective but the
things exist in multiple perspectives so
you know a cubist painting is your face
this way and your face this way at the
same time and so you could say well is
that a more accurate way
of representing a person that just the
standard portrait and Picasso would say
well in some ways definitely because it
captures the transformative element
rather than the static element and so
someone who's a true artist doesn't have
a political message it's funny because
my house is full of ideological
propaganda from the Soviet Union it's
just packed full of it and it's so
interesting to watch these artifacts
because a lot of them were their
Socialist Realist although mostly they
were Impressionists really it's so
interesting to watch them because in
that painting themselves there's a war
that you can perceive and the war is a
lot of the people who made these
paintings were incredibly talented
really really skilled because the
Russians kept their their formal
academies open so the Russians can
really paint Impressionism it's
remarkable but their talents were
encapsulated within this but mostly
Stellan this ideology and so in each
canvas there's this war between the
ideological message and the artistic
message and what's so cool is the
farther we get away from the Soviet
Union the more the art wins because in
300 years there isn't gonna be a shred
left of that ideology and all that will
be left to the pendings is the art so
part of the reason that people are so
attracted to art is because the artist
actually manifests identity with the
process of transformation and so that's
why the artist is a cultural hero that's
also why every nihilist worth his salt
wants to be an artist like who are you
all right what do you say I'm a
nihilists no I'm an artist just like no
you're not but I can see why you want to
be right right yeah just because you're
a failure doesn't mean your Nerdist
well I think it depends on who you are
like it's really interesting to me but
I'm really interested in that you know
and I'm also interested in the way that
ideologies co-opt more fundamental
processes to to and harness their energy
as a rational and motivating force and
so for me these pieces of art propaganda
are extremely interesting I mean it's
very interesting to be surrounded by
them because I can see this war going on
all the time so it's very cool and their
arts winning as far as I can tell so
that's very interesting because they
were pure propaganda many of them when I
bought them but it's getting farther and
farther away from the Soviet Union so
the more archetypal elements are coming
to the forefront